every time we hear these stories tony
everybody thinks maybe this will be the
case this will be the case that will
lead to change and i'm sure they're
saying that same thing in buffalo good
morning to you again
yeah good morning gail that's exactly
what they're saying and i'm joined now
by long time buffalo mayor byron brown
who's been in office for 16 years mr
mayor fair to say you've never seen
anything like this in this area not in
terms of the number of dead or the
motive a hate crime like this i want to
get into all of that but i'm hoping to
begin with the investigation anything
you can share and also the victims have
you had a chance to meet with any of the
families
so i can share about the investigation
that the shooter
came here was a premeditated act
wanted to kill as many black people as
possible
if not for the heroic action of the
security officer retired buffalo police
lieutenant
he would have been more successful in
that effort and if not for the quick
response
of the buffalo police department he
certainly would have killed more people
in this immediate area i have had the
opportunity to speak to our family
members of three of the precious lives
that were lost obviously
this is very painful
for the family certainly something that
no one could prepare themselves for and
as a community we are wrapping our arms
around these families and showing them
uh our love and our care and our concern
it's been interesting talking to people
in the wider community that they all in
some sense feel
like potential victims and therefore
also like survivors because of this
particular market what can you tell us
about the significance of an attack here
at tops
this market was like a center for this
community
it was a hard fight to get the corporate
community
to invest here
this community was a food desert before
this market and tops was one of the
corporations that stepped forward and
said we believe in this community we're
going to invest in
this community
so people have a real uh sense of
importance uh around what this market
means to the community a lot of people
come here
from the immediate community
and from nearby communities and so a lot
of people feel this very personally not
just in the immediate community but in
other places of the city of buffalo and
western new york as well yeah and
unfortunately some people in the area
i've talked to also are afraid not only
about going shopping at a place like
tops in the future but at any place at
any time they feel specifically targeted
what do you say to community members who
are fearful at this time about how
safety can once again feel natural and
normal here in the community
this was a racially motivated attack and
it is scary
to know that that kind of racism and
hate still exists in our country
and unfortunately we've seen too many of
these mass shootings for different
reasons so when something like this
happens it really shakes your feelings
of security and safety
we have said to the community that
we are a safe community
we are a close community and
you can't police your way
out of these these feelings
but we have increased
police patrol
not only in this immediate neighborhood
but in other areas of the city
and hopefully seeing a greater presence
of law enforcement right now in
particular is making people feel more
comfortable yeah the equation here is
tragic and also quite simple it's hate
plus guns equal shootings like this and
if you change the equation you can
change the outcome and i know you're
working on that uh yes
mayor thank you very much for being here
we appreciate it thank you tony